so next question is should all drugs be
legalized I've had this conversation
loads of times before there is countries
such as Portugal where would be a great
example of where the the government
legalized drugs what that doesn't mean
is that you could walk to your local
Marx expenses and buy cocaine or crack
or camine or any of a drug that you want
what it did do was it legalized um so
Portugal for example they did was they
legalized the possession of drugs so if
you got caught with a certain amount
rather than being punished and going
through sort of the Judicial System um
and going to prison or getting a
criminal record which would be held
against you and also add further stigma
and um discrimination I guess to the
person what they did was they legalized
it so if you did get caught with drugs
with possession um unless obviously it
was a huge vast amount where you were
obviously dealing drugs you would um be
offered support and help um which is an
amazing idea um so in that respect yes
it should be